alright so thank you Mary dad for
organizing this wonderful event so what
I'll be talking about today is work done
by Matthew Bella and he is poet vised by
Professor Steven chase and me and all
three of us are here at this meeting and
so feel free to flag any of us down
afterwards to chat and also matt will be
presenting a poster here so feel free to
go go there as well okay so to introduce
how we could centralized internal models
let me just give you a simple
illustration so this is something that
happened yesterday at lunch so I ordered
some clam chowder and as I was reaching
for I realized my neighbor ordered
Lobster and I really wanted that and so
I reached for it how did I successfully
change my mind and get the lobster
without miss Amy okay so you think about
what's going on well my hand is at this
point because of sensory feedback delay
my brain only knows where my hand was a
bit of time in the past right and so if
I were to aim my hand from this delay
this old sensory feedback directly to
the lobster then I would miss the
lobster okay however if instead the
brain my brain used a more intelligent
strategy right whereby I take my
outdated sensory feedback and then
update it using motor commands that my
brain knows that it's sent since then
right using a so called forward model
then I can come up with an estimate of
where my hand currently is and then aim
straight upwards right and successfully
reach for the lobster alright so many
people have studied internal models in
the field and many of them are here in
the room today right and many of these
studies have been on the level of
behavior
right and on the level of single neurons
with behavior so the motivation for
today's talk is the fact that we know
that thought processes are
multi-dimensional right and presumably
the internal models also operate on
these multi-dimensional thought
processes but if we look at behavior
only all right then that's sort of a
low-dimensional readout of what our
brains are doing right and then a
similar story is with single neurons
right and so to try to get at a richer
representation of internal models what
we set out to do was to look at neural
population activity and to ask whether
we could extract a representation of an
internal model that could operate on the
time scale of tens of milliseconds and
also on the spatial scale of individual
neurons and many of them ok so the
outline here is there's two parts so
first I'll talk about using brain
computer interfaces as a tool for
studying internal models and then next
I'll talk about extracting a rich
internal model from neuro population
activity ok so we look at the native arm
control system right there are many
thousands of neurons that project down
the spinal cord and the effector
dynamics are nonlinear with you know
muscle dynamics and so forth and high
dimensional right we are capable of
multi-dimensional movements and there
are many types of sensory feedback
including vision proprioception etc ok
so this makes for a very complicated
system to study and what we're going to
propose here is to use brain computer
interfaces as a simplified motor control
system that has closed loop feedback ok
just study internal models so a a
brain-computer interface right is one in
which we can we record for many neurons
at the same time for example using
electrode array we then passed the
neural activity into a so-called BCI
mapping which translates the neural
activity into movements of a computer
cursor and the subject gets visual
feedback on a moment-by-moment basis
about where the cursor is okay so if we
look at this closely motor control
system what we see is that it's a simple
version of the system we really want to
understand okay and but by maybe using a
BCI system we might be able to get some
foothold on questions like internal
models so if we make this comparison we
typically record from tens of neurons
using these multi electrode arrays and
so in this case we have the full set of
control signals right that are
controlling the cursor by definition
right is only those neurons from which
we're recording directly that can affect
the cursor motion right there are many
other neurons that are playing a role
right in in this right but ultimately
the signals have to pass through the
neurons that were recording for them to
affect cursor motion ok and then
furthermore we get to define the
relationship between the neural activity
and the cursor movements all right and
so we can define them to be linear right
so there could be a linear relationship
between firing rates and cursor velocity
and in this case we have low dimensional
movements because there it's a cursor
moving on a computer screen ok and then
furthermore we can restrict sensory
feedback to be vision only right in this
experiment which makes things simpler ok
so what we're going to set about doing
is to use a brain-computer interface to
study internal models so these
experiments were done by Steve chase
while he was a postdoc in Andy
Schwartz's lab at the University of
Pittsburgh and so just to give you a
quick snapshot on the details of the
experiment so we use one of these 96
electrode a Utah raise employment
implanted in the motor cortex of macaque
monkeys there were 54
experimental sessions combined across
two monkeys I'll show results
individually and also we recorded 15 to
40 single and multi units in each
session and the mapping between the
neural activity and the cursor movements
was a population vector decoder okay
with 33 milliseconds okay so just to
give you a sort of one more layer layer
of detail on what it is that we're
sending into the BCI mapping right what
we have is recording from many neurons
at the same time right each of these
tick marks is a spike right and we're
looking at the activity across all the
neurons that are being recorded and
taking a spike count right for each
other neurons in this 33 milliseconds in
okay that's our that's the control
signal that the animal is sending at
this particular time step okay and then
the next time step it sends another
vector another control signal etc etc
okay so just to give you idea of the
level of control that the monkey is
showing I'm going to play a video right
in this video the green dot is the
cursor which the animal is moving just
by modulating its motor cortical
activity and a blue dot is the target
okay so what you see is that these
movements are relatively straight and
they acquire the targets in less than a
second okay and so they're about half as
good as real arm movements okay so in
this experiment there were 16 targets
around a circle right and you see that
each of these movements are relatively
consistent from trial to trial alright
so the first big question that we're
going to ask is whether these animals
use an internal model during BCI control
right so no one has asked this question
before and before we can use a BCI just
study internal models we first needed to
address this okay so i'm going to show
you two line
of evidence that suggests that these
animals might be using internal models
so the first is by asking the following
question okay so let's say that this is
the cursor trajectory that this is what
happens on the screen right and the
target is here now we're going to ask at
any given moment in time the direction
in which the animal sends the cursor
right which in this case right is in
this direction if we look at the tangent
of the of the cursor trajectory okay
whether that command is more appropriate
at the current time or sometime in the
past right because remember when the
cursor is actually here the animal does
it know that the cursor is here right
its most recent sensory feedback it's
sometime back here all right so the
question is whether it aims from its
most recent sensory feedback which is
outdated somewhere here or whether it
does some sort of internal prediction
all right to estimate that the cursor is
actually here and that aims
appropriately okay so what you're going
to see in the next plot is on the
horizontal axis will be a time delay how
far back in time do we do we shift this
arrow and the vertical axis will be
angular error right which is if this
arrow goes right to the target that
would be zero degrees error but if the
arrow would miss the target then you
would get a positive error ok so if
hypothetically right if the subject
aimed from its most current visual
feedback right which is old and stale
right then what we would see is that the
angular error would look something like
this which is that the angler error
would be smallest at the visual feedback
delay whatever it is right which people
estimate to be around 100 milliseconds
for motor cortex okay what we saw okay
in our analyses with real data was that
this minimum was actually at zero
seconds right which indicates that the
command that the animals sending at any
given time is most appropriate for the
current cursor position okay that the
animal doesn't actually see right rather
than its most recent sensory feedback
okay and so this suggests that the
subject uses an internal model to
predict the current cursor position
alright so that's the first line of
evidence the second line of evidence is
by leveraging an aspect of BC is which
is changing the BCI mapping right
because we as experimenters we can
change the relationship between the
neural activity and the cursor velocity
so that's what we did okay and what I'm
showing you here is the first trial
after this mapping was switched ok so
our hypothesis was that the animal on
this trial would still be using right an
internal model appropriate for the first
mapping right because the change was uh
was made unbeknownst to the animal ok so
in black here is the cursor trajectory
that the animal saw on the screen on
this first trial ok and what we did in
post hoc analyses was to pass the same
neural activity through the first
mapping right to see how appropriate it
would have been right for the first
mapping ok so let's say we take we start
at this time point right on the actual
trajectory ok and if we pass that the
neural activity in the in the time steps
coming up through the second mapping we
of course trace out this trajectory
however if we pass the same neural
activity through the first mapping we
get this different trajectory which we
call a whisker and what we notice here
is that this whisker points right to the
target right as if the neural activity
that the animal was sending
right was appropriate for the first
mapping but not for the second okay we
can do this okay at all the time points
okay and what the thing that jumps out
at us is that even though their cursor
trajectory at times is not going
directly to the target right and other
times is right all these whiskers tend
to point right to the target right and
so this is an indication that the
subject continue to use an internal
model that was consistent with the first
mapping right even when the second
mapping was was was the one that was
actually under operation okay so with
these two lines of evidence okay what we
set out to do was to try to extract a
rich internal model from neural
population activity during closed loop
brain computer interface control okay so
I don't have time to get into the
details of how we did this but let me
give you the main ideas ok so the BCI
mapping that was used took on this form
ok where X is a stay of the cursor right
so this is position and velocity ok and
you is this vector of neural activity
the spike counts right a given off by
the neurons that we're recording from
simultaneously at one time step ok and
then a B and little B are the matrices
that define the mapping ok so what we
attempted to do was to extract an
internal model ok of this form ok so you
notice that takes exactly the same form
as the mapping itself and we did this
both out of mathematical convenience ok
and due to the fact that if the animal
learn a perfect internal model right it
should fall within this family ok and so
the parameters that define the internal
model are a tilde be Big B tilde and
little B tilde ok the X tilde here is
the subject
internal conception of where the cursor
is going alright some sort of internal
tracking state variable okay and then
you notice here that the you doesn't
have a chill de on it okay it's a saying
you as up here okay he's using his
neural activity or his motor command
that he knows that he sent okay to try
to do this internal tracking ok so the
internal model estimation problem okay
can be succinctly stated as follows so
what we can observe in the experiment
are the cursor trajectories right this
is what actually happened on the screen
right the neural population activity
that we recorded right this is the
activity that was controlling the cursor
and then also knowledge of pascal's
right where was it target okay and what
we seek to find right are the parameters
of the internal model a tilde tilde and
little view tilde also the internal
state predictions right every moment in
time right where did the animal think
the cursor was ok this is the X tilde
variables and also the visual feedback
delay which we call tau okay so you
might be asking yourself at this point
all right we're recording using
electrode array in motor cortex why do
we even how do we even stand a chance of
trunk extract the internal model when we
don't we when we are recording from the
area that presumably is not the main
area involved in implementing this
internal model right probably cerebellum
is right and furthermore we have no
evidence that we're recording corollary
discharge right ok so the rationale for
this is the following alright that if an
internal model is being used somewhere
in the motor control system and that the
neurons that we're recording from in the
motor cortex are downstream from that
internal model then presumably the
activity that we're recording reflects
whatever computations are being
performed by the internal model okay so
by looking at the neural activity we
should be able to deduce something about
the internal model
and secondly we take the m1 activity
that we record as a proxy for corollary
discharge right so if the m1 activity is
reflecting the subjects intentions right
of where to move the cursor then
presumably the core layer discharge is
primarily carrying that information as
well all right so just to give you some
intuition for what this internal model
estimation procedure does ok so let's
take one particular time ok so let's say
that the cursor right is moving on the
screen in this direction ok and let's
say that the animal is sitting at this
time ok where the cursor is here right
but the animal doesn't actually know
that the cursors here right and the most
recent sensory feedback that the animal
received was for say here ok and so what
the animal should do is they should take
its most recent sensory feedback and
then propagate it forward in time using
its internal model and the neural
activity it knows it has sent since then
ok to come up with an estimate an
internal estimate of where it thinks the
cursor is alright so you notice here
that there's a mismatch between where
the cursor currently actually is versus
where the animal thinks it is right and
so what the animal should do at this
time point right in terms of how it
decides what is the next neural command
to send out is to then aim straight to
the target from this point right not
this point right
okay and so if that same neural activity
that the animal sends right to move from
the current internal estimate towards
the target that same neural activity
vector U of T when passed through the
actual mapping might send the cursor on
the screen in this other direction okay
so this is the intuition right behind
this internal model estimation problem
right we want to find these parameters
of the internal model this h-hold a big
B tilde a little B tilde okay such that
at each time point this is true write
that using the same set of parameters at
any moment right the internal estimate
of the cursor position is a one that's
appropriate for sending the cursor
straight to the target okay so we took
many trials right from one session we
did this across many sessions but we
analyzed one session at a time we took
many trials right and we fit this
internal model get to the data okay and
we did this using an exact eem algorithm
and a part of this procedure it was to
estimate this sensory feedback delay
right so in the in the picture that I
showed you how many times that should
back should we go right for for for this
estimation of that whisker to come out
okay and that's a model selection
problem okay and what we found was that
a feedback delay of three time steps
which corresponds to approximately 100
milliseconds was most appropriate for
the data okay and this is consistent
with previous studies that show that
that motor cortex reflects visual input
after about a hundred milliseconds okay
and then all the results i'm going to
show our cross-validated yeah but that
always assumes that the target is moving
at the same rate thank you charge it is
fixed so the target is shown at the
beginning of the trial and it's fixed
but you have to aim for a moving target
it's fixed that only the cursor that the
animals controlling is go ok yeah ok
yeah ok so here is an example held out
trial ok so here the target is here and
the cursor it was moving along this
trajectory and so let's just look at
this time point right here right this is
where the cursor is now so remember that
at this moment in time the animal
doesn't know that the cursor is actually
here ok and the the neural command that
the animal sends at this time point
sends the cursor in this downwards
direction ok and that's a 45 degree
error because it misses the target by 45
degrees ok in comparison right if we
take our the internal model that we
estimated right and we say okay what
would what would the M will do at this
time point what go back three time steps
right to its most recent sensory
feedback and then propagate that
position forward in time by three time
steps it comes up with an internal
estimate of where the cursor currently
actually is right which disagrees with
where it is on the screen ok and so in
this particular example right the neural
activity that the animal sends right
goes straight to the target according to
where the monkey thinks the cursor is ok
so this would encourage zero degrees
error ok so now we can compare these two
different types of errors right the
error that actually occurred on the
screen which was 45 degrees at this time
step versus the error that was in the
monkeys mind in some sense right which
in this case was zero degrees yeah
every snake monkey in the training
trials we needed to assume that right
parameters of the internal model well
then this is a held out trial right
which was not used in model fitting and
so what we did was to take those
parameters and the neural activity that
we reported on this trial to then
propagate this sensory feedback forward
in time to arrive at this point and then
we use the neural activity that we
record it at the next time point to then
ask what where does that send the
monkeys internal estimate okay all right
so we can look at these whiskers right
across all the time was right and what
the thing that turns out right is that
most if not all of these losers point
straight to the target right even during
times when the cursor is not going
straight to the target on the screen
right and so before we did this study
right we would we would sometimes sea
trials like this right where the cursor
goes off in different directions that
don't seem to make sense in terms of the
task okay but having done this having
now interpreted right these same trials
in terms of an internal model it all
seems to make sense now right in that
the errors that the animal was making
was not due to some sort of random noise
right or some moments of laps lapses of
attention right what seems to be going
on is that these errors are structured
okay and that it's because the animal
was using an internal model that was
mismatched from the actual be Emma BCI
mapping right so under this
interpretation right it seems like the
animal is acting rationally right even
though without seeing these red whiskers
we would have thought just looking at
the black trace that the animal were
somehow acting irrational okay so that
was one held out trial we can look at a
bunch of held out trials right and the
thing that you know really stands out
here is that there are times when the
cursor is going straight to the target
and during those times the whiskers
align with where the where the cursor is
actually going on the screen and then
there are times when the cursor is not
going straight to the target and during
those times the whiskers point to the
target right and don't align with the
actual cursor directory okay and so it
seems like across all of these trials
right whether or not the cursor is
actually going to the target right what
the animal internally thinks is going on
right is that it's always trying to push
the cursor straight to the target okay
so we can quantify this right so we can
measure these angular errors okay and
what you see is it's a vertical axis
here is angular error all right the
first bar here is the cursor air which
is the error of what the end will
actually saw on the screen and then the
second bar here is the error according
to the internal model okay and what we
see is that by interpreting right the
population activity in terms of the
internal model we can account for over
sixty five percent of the errors that
the animal is making on the screen so
the key idea right this is the key
result right and so the main message
here right is that when there's a
mismatch between the animals internal
model and what is actually going on in
the outside world right you can get
errors from that and in this particular
task we can account for a large
percentage of the errors right bye-bye
accounting for this mismatch
okay so I don't have time to get into
additional analyses that we did but let
me just tell you what they are so we
also found that when we change the BMI
the BCI mapping right that the internal
model also adapted in accordance to the
new mapping okay secondly we found that
subjects attempted to move more slowly
during hold periods and more quickly
during movement periods okay as if this
mismatch between the internal model and
the BCI mapping right actually decreased
the dynamic range of speeds right the
animal had some trouble stopping and
some trouble some trouble moving quickly
right and we could see that by
interpreting the neural activity in
terms of an internal model and
furthermore this mapping right from the
high dimensional neural activity to low
dimensional cursor kinematics was
essential to the explanatory power of
this internal model right and so we can
see that in the this equation right that
defines our internal model where the key
term here is this be til de UT alright
so be tilde here is short and fat right
and you is a vector of the neural
activity right and so this operation of
B times you right is a mapping from this
high dimensional neural space down to a
low dimensional kinematics pace okay and
this mapping was critical right and we
assess this by replacing this neural
activity with cursor velocities right
that we're actually shown on the screen
and we found that we could not explain
the errors even close to the extent that
we were able to by using the neural
activity
okay so to summarize right what I've
shown is that b/ci facilitates the study
of internal models because we can view
it as a simplified closed-loop motor
control system we developed a
statistical framework for estimating a
rich internal model right from neural
population activity right that operates
at the time scale of tens of
milliseconds at the spatial scale of
individual neurons and we found that a
mismatch between the internal model and
the actual BCI mapping can account for
sixty-five percent of the animals errors
right and then finally the sort of
broader message right is that population
activity can provide insights about the
internal model that may be difficult to
see through behavior alone all right
because the neural population activity
reflects these multi-dimensional thought
processes all right that's it